it's 10 GMT and we begin this NewsHour
with Ukraine and Russia accusing each
other of blowing up a major Dam that
sparking warnings of severe flooding in
russian-controlled territory Downstream
of the dam in the region of Curson water
levels they have risen by 10 meters the
Nova kakov kadam links the banks of the
dinipro river held by Russia on the
south side to Kiev on the North the
mayor there says at least 600 houses
have been flooded and people are being
evacuated further up the river is these
operation nuclear power plant but the
iaea says it faces no immediate risk
Stephanie Decker begins our coverage
a massive surge of water at the kakova
dam in the Hassan region of Southern
Ukraine after an explosion in the early
hours of Tuesday this area is under the
control of Russian forces Russia blames
Ukraine for this Ukraine blames Russia
the Russian installed mayor of
novajarhovah the area surrounding the
dam appeared on Russian TV
first of all the kahova hydroelectric
power station has been destroyed because
of multiple strikes currently the water
level continues to rise for those who
know the town it is already at the nepro
Avenue the dam is being washed away we
are evacuating people that are
Downstream a large number of
infrastructure objects have already been
flooded sewage pumping stations power
lines were destroyed some houses too
water is Flowing down uncontrollably
this was the dam before the explosion it
stands 30 meters tall and 3.2 kilometers
long and built in 1956 River as part of
the kahova hydroelectric power plant it
also supplies water to the Crimean
Peninsula annexed by Russia in 2014
water from the dam is essential for
cooling Europe's largest nuclear power
plant in zappariza Russia controls the
plant and along with Ukraine's State
Atomic power agency and the UN nuclear
Watchdog the iaea have all said the
situation at the plant is under control
the waters have submerged parts of
novocarkova the Russians say water
levels will continue to rise for about
72 hours and then start to go down it
was not immediately clear however how
the flood waters would affect Ukraine's
long-planned counter-offensive against
Russian forces who are dug in across
Southern and Eastern Ukraine Stephanie
Decker Al Jazeera
well let's now speak to journalist Julia
chapovalova who's live from Moscow Yulia
the ukrainians accusing Russia of
blowing up this Dam what our authorities
in Moscow and the Russian control region
of Curson saying about this
so as we understand uh some pro-russian
authorities of the Novak Healthcare
denies the accusations that Russia was
behind the destruction of the station uh
the Russian appointed mayor of the town
of Norway said that the destruction of
this station was a catastrophe and it
was created by the Ukrainian authorities
and those who controlled them he also
said that the Ukrainian Armed Forces
continued at the shelling of the town of
Norway and the authorities were figuring
out how to evacuate people from there
and the authorities also said that the
kehovska hydroelectric power station
cannot be restored it will have to be
built from scratch now according to
acting governor of the Herson region of
Vladimir salda the Armed Forces of
Ukraine decided to damage the food
security of the Harrison region by
destroying the hydroelectric power
station in order to divert attention
from the failures in the so-called
Ukrainian counter-offensive but he added
that the situation will not prevent the
Russian forces from protecting the Left
Bank of the Nipper River in the Herson
region Julia a vital Channel I
understand carrying water from the
dinipro river to Russian occupied Crimea
which starts at the Novak Kafka is also
likely to be affected what are you
hearing about the situation in Crimea
yeah sure but first according to active
acting governor of the Herson region
again Vladimir salda the destruction of
the dam has led to to the flooding and
even washing away of agricultural Fields
along the river nipro and it has led to
the flow of a large but not critical
amount of water in the NEPA River
therefore the evacuation of a large
number of people will not be required
that's correct the Ukrainian side
earlier on pointed out that the
explosions at the uh kahovska Power
Station meant that the Crimea the
Crimean Peninsula would be left without
water that's according to uh but
according to the head of Crimea Sergey
axionev there is a risk that shallow
water in the North Korean Canal might be
one of the consequences of that
situation also the Ukrainian side as
well as head of the IAA Rafael Grossi
have said that the situation creates
risks for the separation nuclear power
plant due to the possible shortage of
water to cool down the reactions but
according to an advisor to to the head
of Russia's Ross energo atom the water
in the pools of this operation nuclear
plants a plant actually are not used to
cool down the reactors and there is no
connection at all with the kahovka
reservoir with the pools that's what
we're hearing
um at their end well right the iaea has
also said that there is no immediate
risk to these aberration nuclear power
plant Julia thank you very much for that
Julia shop of all of our live there in
Moscow well let's discuss this all
further now with Andrea resenko who's a
fellow at the center for defense
strategies in Ukraine he's also a
retired captain of Ukraine's Navy and
former assistant to the Ukrainian
Minister of Defense thank you very much
Mr rizenko for being with us on Al
Jazeera can I ask you first what
evidence Ukraine has that Russia blew up
the Nova kakov kadam
yeah first of all character of
distractions and shows that it's quite
extensive destruction 11 out of 28
section of the down were destroyed and
actually this is Possible only in case
of preposition explosive and currently
Ukrainian military they assessing how
much explosive can cause such a
tremendous
damage of the of this Dom and the
electric power plant at all because
electric power plant actually destroyed
and it's it cannot happen just as a
consequence of the of the artillery
strike or rocket strike and also some
witnesses who actually observed this
explosion they said it was like in turn
of explosion in inside of them uh inside
of the dam at not any incoming artillery
or orchids right so so are the
ukrainians saying sorry to interrupt you
so are the ukrainians saying that the
Russians are responsible based on
eyewitnesses
uh yes yeah yeah
is that enough uh uh evidence to blame
Russia
uh yeah now they collecting also it's
important to see how much explosive
actually caused such tremendous damages
actually because uh because again it's
it's the most probably it's the tons of
explosives it's not not actually uh tens
of kilograms which can be brought by
artillery shells or even Rockets
actually and this is this is a this is
white and we know that they start to
collect this explosive in in
novakov Hydro Electric Plant starting
from last fall okay and also some of the
people or some saying that it can be
Russians but actually their plan was to
make small explosion to break this
bridge or which located on the top of
the dump not Ukrainian troops to cross
it okay I was going to ask you about
that let me just pick up on what you've
been saying uh please sir so uh Ukraine
blames Russia based on I when eyewitness
accounts mostly let me ask you now uh
what evidence what you know would Russia
why what would Russia gain from doing
this why would the Russians have done
this how does a destruction of this damn
affect Dynamics on the battlefield what
do they gain from this
uh yeah actually uh
if the four Russians doesn't
many troops on the Left Bank of the
nipple or Europe in this direction they
considerated most of the of the troops a
little bit to the north of of this area
close to the Parisian city
and they probably try to prevent
Crossing via Bridge or only actually
exist in Bridge
located on on the top of the dump of the
kakova
electric power plant but probably they
miscalculated and this miscalculation
caused the much greater explosion than
they actually
planned and because also from from
Witnesses Russians were extremely like
surprised with the consequences of this
flooding because the the some of their
troops located very close to the to the
to the to the coastline on the Left Bank
of the river okay now Mr rizenko so you
say the Russians could have done this to
to stop Ukrainian advances further south
and we've seen in the past few days
there's clearly been a push by the
Ukrainian military even if they're not
officially saying that this is the start
of the long awaited counter-offensive uh
they've been planning we've seen a push
by the Ukrainian military how does the
destruction of this Dam affect Ukraine's
plans and Ukraine is counter-offensive
I think not much because
um not much because mostly it's like um
it's just harm and and huge and the
danger for the population for Ukrainian
citizens living on above banks of the
neighbor or you are in total it's a
estimation around 300 000 people can
live in this area but this number of
just before War speaking about military
plans it's not changing too much because
this flooding can happen just maybe 10
kilometers uh from each cost of the
nepro river it's it's quite far away to
the access to the Crimea Peninsula and
uh and actually it will not change much
actually
maybe even all plans for them because
this uh counteroffensification thank you
for sharing your views with us Andrea
retired captain of Ukraine's Navy and a
former assistant to Ukraine's Minister
of Defense joining us there from Keith
thank you for your time